yeah you already know I'm Gilly the king
my load to 67 and we are the the
gracious host of million dollars worth
for gaming podcast now we about the
answer some questions some crazy
questions would you for all of his
nothing oh I'm definitely not doing my
hands just meet LeBron James and let it
[ __ ] five-foot-nine I'm still not gonna
leave LeBron James he's a tag blower he
said he's a [ __ ] or too short whistle
that's a filthy question he's a filthy
animal this not get done would you
rather the world lost women or all
sports sports sports [ __ ] that I will
sit around watch the Sixers game with my
dick hard dick on the shelf on the ship
no you gotta get your dick up off the
shelf
yeah if you can be a superstar athlete
in any sport but you couldn't have sex
would you do it no I was I would listen
I wouldn't you know why I do it
jerking off is not counted as sex bro
did but who the [ __ ] wants to have a
shitload of money in jerking off like no
I would rather have me
no no I think I think I've ever driven
I think I'll be able to jerk off him
quit me just tell you something the
perks of having a shitload of money and
being a superstar athlete is the women
that come by the spicy boys your spicy
boys Podcast to you by Moore's movies
sports too spicy brothers loosening the
pepper in it
the spicy boys this one Chili Bowl Chili
Bowl a jalapeno which NFL team would win
all white players or all black players
oh that's [ __ ] easy man
that's why would you that's like come on
man think about this think about this I
got Jerry Rice I got Emma Smith oh oh my
god what's name Baltimore oh is this
[ __ ] right here y'all in trouble is it
done y'all [ __ ] up is over
they got Kirsten McAskill Christian crew
up Kristin definitely go with some
[ __ ] you can tell the cuts the hell
Christian cuts is like [ __ ] Reez cuts
with someone else put up like he was
playing the playground he was playing on
TV Creed he was running around with
Jamal down they was planted football in
a basketball court Jamal and Raheem and
boo-boo coming to get Christian yeah hey
come on Omar Marcy come on would you
rather sleep with a sexy [ __ ] or a
below-average
right now I'm [ __ ] the [ __ ] brings
up because the lower you little [ __ ]
you spit oh you dick like a time like a
bottle top
your spit on your job [ __ ] be having
fat answers yes they do does they be
built low to the ground like a Honda
[ __ ] baby no baby compact like very
really do you see a slim [ __ ] [ __ ]
we having some asses on yes they doing
how many rats would it take to overwhelm
and kill you in a fight
damn how many rats oh you know rats they
big they fight shot damn it take two
they jump on me I pass ha ha I gotta
take at least quite like 15 to 20 cuz
imma fight them off I'm like I no more
short so it's not gonna be easy
would you rather have 50 grand straight
to your bank account or a half a million
in pennies and you haven't finished you
won't convert you won't count on me they
said you can't convert it oh man give me
50 thousand 50 thousand I got [ __ ] I got
to do cuz I'd be dead like I'll be
damned if I'm a being chick fillet with
painful pay for ten dollars you gotta go
get some Easy's and pennies like no
that's that's I said that's a nerd add
on you image like yeah you [ __ ] you
ain't get no money got pennies he
counted would you bang your cousin to
win the POW ye [ __ ] you know no no not
[ __ ] info I'm not [ __ ] that it's not
gonna happen
spicy [ __ ] that's a spicy question no
you freak my ball one of my cousin's the
[ __ ] that's the reverse the damage
no comments that's a little spicy
powerful awful Powerball for money power
boss would you [ __ ] a porn star if
afterwards she had to hold a press
conference on your performance
absolutely yes sir I'm [ __ ] listen man
I'm baby late cuz all he's gonna do is
it's gonna give me a bunch of a
publicity cuz she look like that he had
that [ __ ] in my chest plate that
[ __ ] was in my chest I felt it
between my breasts like I couldn't
breathe
he stopped my heart for a moment
understand you a porn star you might
have to you know 800 Knicks today this
might be the dark deep hole so you know
sometimes when you get to that point you
gotta HIVs hitter another yes hit
initiative would you be the world's most
dominant one-on-one basketball player if
everyone forced to play naked okay who
would be me me run around what cuz I
don't know in order to be a hell of a
basketball player naked you got no no no
no it ain't about the baby they mean
that means you Spice shorty that means
you spicy though if you want to play
Mickey the [ __ ] out here like this will
you post you turn around you like this
I'm saying that's what they do it sports
that that's what they do in sports good
game good game
okay that's what they do just like
that's why yeah come on we gotta do ya
ass ring your ass Rick just killing you
all did whoa
like come on man ain't nobody got time
for that [ __ ] every time you finish sex
a song please what we
you wanted to be he's a maniac Oh see
the stick that's gonna be my song stop
toy it up eat it up beat it up speed it
up
bang I killed him like think about that
[ __ ] man hey probably whatever I believe
I can fly
[Applause]
that's the door to our heavy [ __ ] felt
like she was crazy